Xin chào mừng các bạn đến với khoa học
excel miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao
dành cho người mới bắt đầu được thực
hiện trên kênh YouTube là Excel bài số
22 tạo báo cáo động đất lót trước khi
bắt đầu vào bài học số 22 mình sẽ giải
cái câu hỏi của bài tập số 2 một hôm
trước nhé yêu cầu của Đề Bà Rịa mình rất
tính cái giá trị nhỏ nhất mà lớn không
Nhá cái ly ở đây mình sẽ ghi là địa lớn
không đấy nếu như bạn tính lên bình
thường thì nó sẽ ra là không đúng không
Tại vì những cái ô này có những cái
tháng mà các bạn này nó không làm gì cả
đúng không Thì doanh thu nó sẽ bằng
không đấy có rất nhiều tháng và các bạn
ấy bằng không Bây giờ mình sẽ tính cái
doanh thu nhỏ nhất mà là diện phải lớn
hơn không đấy thì mình làm như thế nào
để họ sẽ bằng nhá thì tính nhỏ nhất thì
bạn phải dùng hàm yên rồi đúng không ạ
nhìn các bạn mở Hoặc ra thì bạn sử dụng
cái hàng ít nhá ít là dễ cái biểu thức
lôgic của mình là toàn bộ cái vùng dữ
liệu ở đây Đấy nó sẽ diện lớn đúng không
nó ấy cần phải nhắn nếu như lớn không
hiện gì à Có sao vẫn trả về cái vùng rữa
tin tức là mình chỉ xét những cái ô lớn
không Thôi để mình hiểu đơn giản là như
vậy tao sẽ đóng ngoặc lại để xong cái Hà
mít này có thể dẫn đóng ngoặc đơn lại để
xong Hà Min và các bạn giữ cần ship ở
nhà thơ đấy thì nó sẽ trả về 13 Họ sẽ
tiếp bước vào đây ví dụ về U13 mình sẽ
thay bằng điện bằng 223 ảnh thế nhá chọn
enter lấy thì lúc này nhỏ nhất là 21 là
giá trị ở đây và nó sẽ bỏ qua những cái
ô mà có giá trị không nhá Đấy tương tự ở
đây cũng thế nhá Ok mình sẽ đóng lại
mình sẽ vào bài học ngày hôm nay là bài
khá là hay mình sẽ tạo một cái báo có
động tác bóp nhé các bạn sẽ thích đút
vào đây Okay Đây là cái vùng dữ liệu của
mình nhá đại dữ liệu của mình rất là lớn
này để cả năm trở xuống này Đấy là có
gần 5.000 dòng nữa đấy để tạo đ-sport
thì mình sẽ sử dụng Viber table vào
slicer nhé Thì như bài học file word
table mình đã hướng dẫn được trước rồi
thì trước khi bắt đầu tạo cái bios thấy
bổ thì tốt nhất
Anh chuyển cái vùng dữ liệu này thành
thay bộ trước để làm gì để cái dữ liệu
nó sẽ tự động nó sẽ cập nhật khi mà các
bạn thêm dữ liệu mới vào đúng ạ Đấy thì
đầu tiên mình sẽ tạo thay đổi cho cái
vùng dữ liệu các bạn sẽ thích bằng ô bất
kỳ sau đó gọn xem vào cái thẻ Insert và
các bạn sẽ thích cái Thay bồ đây hoặc là
gì à cao sẽ ấn can t đấy thì nó sẽ có
một cái cửa sổ created thay bộ được hiện
ra đúng không nó sẽ lựa chọn từ việc đầu
tiên đến với yêu cuối cùng các bạn Nhớ
thích chọn mai thấy bố hết đời nhá này
sau đó bạn sẽ thích ok đấy thì như vậy
cái vùng dữ liệu của mình đã được tạo
thành Tây mồm bên trái này là cái thấy
buồn đêm thì đây là tên mặc định nhá các
bạn có thể dùng cái tên này hoặc các bạn
đổi tên cũng được ví dụ mình đổi tên là
diện dữ liệu đi cái và Họ sẽ ở Master
thì như vậy mình đã có một cách thay bồ
dữ liệu rồi đúng không Bây giờ các bạn
xem vào thẻ Insert này các bạn sẽ chọn
bài post thêm đấy thì một cái cửa sổ
christie's Facebook tê bồ đã hiện ra
đúng không
từ đó tạo pivot table chính là cái tên
dữ liệu mà nói với mình Đạt bạn đấy
Ngoài ra thì ở đây nó sẽ có hai cái tùy
chọn là diễn tạo cái xít để chứa file
word p.bồ thông thường mình sẽ thích vào
đây tức là mình sẽ tạo một cái xít mới
đúng không các bạn sẽ bấm ok thì như vậy
nó sẽ tạo của cái sim mới là ship hay là
cái ship mà chứa file Portable đúng
không Thì đầu tiên nhá mình sẽ kéo hiện
ví dụ mình sẽ kéo cái trường năm và lâu
này trường tháng mình sẽ kéo vào đây Đấy
cái doanh thu còn sẽ kéo xuống đây đấy
ngoài ra nhé bạn sẽ vào cái thẻ design
này cái phần Zippo gian mình sẽ chọn là
sâu Winter Ballad đi tiếp theo bạn sẽ
chuyển sang cái thẻ like nhé Mình sẽ
chọn cái Viber trả lại đây đấy thì với
cái trường hợp mà này thì có thể ví dụ
mình chọn cái chặt đầu tiên này đi chọn
ca lần này nhá lại gọi sân bấm ok thì
như vậy đây là cái dữ liệu về doanh thu
họ sẽ nhấn chuột phải vào đây các bạn sẽ
chọn 2 ô này lên lại mình không cần các
thông tin này cái tôi tờ bạn tích vào
đây Bạn bấm delete
anh Thái Cái đây là cái tiêu đề đúng
không còn sẽ thích lúc vào đây ví dụ
mình đi lại doanh thu lại Ví dụ mình cho
căn sang phải đi cả có thể tích vào đây
này các bạn sẽ bỏ cái rồi lại đi lại
mình sẽ không cần yêu biết lại đây Bây
giờ mình rất thích vào giá trị mất kìa
đây nhá Sau đó bạn sẽ nhấn phải lại mình
sẽ format đây ta series đấy và mình sẽ
rẻ mình sẽ con nhỏ cái khác này lại nhìn
nó đẹp hơn đúng không Lại cậu sẽ đóng
cái này lại nhé ok lại bạn thấy cho mình
đã có một cái doanh thu khá là đẹp rồi
mình sẽ con nhỏ cái này lại bây giờ nhắc
bạn thấy mình sẽ nháy chuột phải vào cái
này các bạn sẽ chọn gì mình sẽ chọn pho
mát
bộ sạc LG sản xuất tích vào điện đây là
trong cái thẻ khi like Là người cho vào
cái phần Bưu đời Các bạn sẽ chọn với số
nice Life Ví dụ mình chọn màu là màu cam
đi Vĩnh màu cam là cái Độ rộng là cái
quýt này mình sẽ đẻ là gì mình cho đẻ 3t
đi hoặc hai thì các bạn nhé đấy các bạn
thấy bao nhiêu thì ví dụ như thứ ba là
đẹp các bạn kéo xuống dưới mình sẽ chọn
lâu KL các hàng cây góc này nó sẽ bỏ lại
lại nhìn nó đẹp hơn của hoa quả sẽ đóng
này quá đấy Đây là cái bộ đồ này màu cam
và diện nó sẽ Bó này ạ bây giờ diện mình
sẽ tạo một cái sim mới thích vào dấu
cộng này các bạn sẽ tích lũy vào đây
mình sẽ sửa tên Ví dụ mình đi đã Sports
đấy Cái dancesport này gọi sẽ kéo ra
ngoài nhá lại cái ship hay là cái
Facebook thì vừa xong các bạn có thể
tích nước vào đây mình sẽ ghi là giữa
doanh thu đã gặp m bây giờ có suy nháy
chuột phải vào cái file gốc Tràm này còn
Coffee các bạn chuyển sang cái đã sport
nhé đấy bạn sẽ thích ở đây bạn sẽ ăn
chương v e
3 cách là mình sẽ copy cái trả lại thôi
Ví dụ mình sẽ ko nhỏ này lại Bây giờ
mình sẽ trang trí với sport này nhá lại
Bây giờ mình sẽ mình sẽ tích và cái bát
sport này mình sẽ vào cái alike các bạn
sẽ chọn là insolite đi mình sẽ chọn là
diện năm này tháng này khu vực nhà phân
phối đã mình sắp tạo 4S hay sơn lại họ
sẽ tích bằng 5 nhá mình có 35 thì hẳn
Thế nhá Mình sẽ vào với ôsin người rất
để nó thành ba cái cột này lại năm mình
sẽ để lên trên này lại các bạn sẽ kéo
sang góc này nhé Tiếp theo là cái tháng
nha cậu thích vào đây ví dụ mình cho là
bốn tháng rồi đi lại đây là cái vùng
điều khiển nhé Tiếp theo là cái
cho ví dụ mình khu vực thì mình có thể
Cứ để ba khu vực hoặc là mình khu vực
1973 này đi Hạnh ca nhà phân phối bạn
tích vào đây ví dụ mình sẽ cho là hai
đây mình sẽ đẻ ra hai cục quá Ok thì các
bạn sẽ co kéo nào cho phù hợp với cả cái
vùng ĐT mà các bạn mong muốn nhé tiếp
theo mình sẽ tạo một cái các bạn sẽ
thích vào cái bios mà về doanh thu là
đấy các bạn giữ cần chôn và các bạn giữ
được trái còn kéo nhé Tức là mình sẽ
copy cái sân này ra một cái sim mới Tức
là mình sẽ tạo một cái cốc sạc từ cái
mình đã có nhá mình tạo nhanh tiếp theo
mình sẽ tạo cái gì anh Doanh thu theo Ví
dụ mình theo khu vực hạn thế nhá Cái nào
mà có cần theo dõi thì gọi làm nhá mình
sẽ thích và ra còn vào thể like nhé mày
chọn cái kiểu lít ở đây thì là gì ạ Mình
sẽ
ở khu vực đã rạch kéo khu vực vào cái
Leesin này Đấy cảm thấy bây giờ mình sẽ
nháy chuột phải vào đây mình dẫn đổi cái
kiểu tràn nhé các bạn chọn là chào trên
trà xanh đấy Gọi sẽ chọn cái like lại đi
đấy Chắc bấm ok thì như vậy Cái đồ thị
này nó sẽ biểu diễn like này đấy bạn có
thể diện ko rất nhớ được sản Coffee luôn
mình sẽ xanh đấy cẩn desktop mà các bạn
canvê luôn mình hết cái đất bóp này nhá
Để bây giờ mình sẽ kéo cái đã post này
để nó bằng cái cái này nói tiền thì lên
đây à
ở đây là cái cách mà chọn bố trí nhìn
cho nó đẹp thôi ví dụ là doanh thu theo
khu vực chẳng hạn đấy đúng không Bạn
thích ở đây mình sẽ sửa lại doanh thu
này theo khu vực
Ừ anh thu hiện theo khu vực Quốc Bây giờ
có thật sự thích vào dấu cộng này mình
sẽ thêm cái Legend vào đây mình sẽ biết
là màu làm miền nào đúng không còn kéo
lên đây mình kéo ngang ra à
ừ ừ
ở lại miền Bắc một nào miền Nam một màu
thì chung nghiệp nào có bạn nhìn này thì
còn thấy là Việt Nam Doanh thu là cao
nhất đúng không miền Trung là doanh thư
thứ hai và miền Bắc là doanh thu thấp
nhất đấy các bạn sẽ tích và cái màu này
nhá Đấy sau đó bạn nhấp nháy chuột phải
hoặc các bạn có thể ấn can trên một để
mình hiện cái format date asiri đúng
không đấy bạn chú ý nhau mình sẽ vào cái
phần phim này lăn xuống người cho chọn
xin 1like đi Nhìn nó đẹp hơn đúng không
Đấy nhìn uốn lượn này nó đẹp hơn để họ
sẽ tích và tiếp theo cái đồ thị của miền
Trung và hạ thế mình cũng chọn một like
đi miền Nam Bộ thế Mình rất nhút lại đi
Đấy nhìn nó đẹp hơn thì như vậy mình đã
có hai cái biểu đồ là gì Một cái là theo
doanh thu theo năm ở đây và các tháng
một cái là chia ra thêm cái phần khu vực
để mình xem giám sát xem là cái khu vực
nào là tốt nhất đúng không tiếp theo nha
cạn lợi dụng những cái Facebook mình đã
có rồi Các bạn có thể nhai phải này các
bạn ngu copy
Ừ để mình sẽ tiết ở đây clip tiếp tục
Coffee các bạn tích bảo vệ sinh một này
thì ok Bây giờ mình sẽ tạo một cái về
cái sản phẩm nha bạn Facebook và đây là
mình sửa lại ví dụ sản phẩm Top đi top 3
đi đấy các bạn sẽ thích và đến biểu đồ
này đúng không các bạn sẽ nháy chuột
phải này mình sẽ chặn trên trả sau đây
mình sẽ chọn những ba này họ sẽ bấm ok
Bây giờ các bạn xem vào cái thẻ alike
chọn finish này thì bạn sẽ kéo vớ ra bạn
bỏ khu vực da bây giờ mình chỉ là sản
phẩm hơn đúng không ạ Và còn sẽ kéo sản
phẩm vào đây đấy thì như vậy đấy có 10
sản phẩm Đúng không các bạn tích vào đây
là các bạn sẽ chọn gì ạ ra lưu filter
Mình sẽ chọn tích và cái top 10 đây mình
sẽ sửa cái số 10 thì số ba đâu đấy Có ba
đó không có sẽ bấm ok lấy thì như vậy Ở
đây nó chỉ hiện ba cái sản phẩm và có
doanh thu các bạn nhé việc phải
khi chọn sọt nha ví dụ từ cao xuống thấp
đấy thì cái đồ thị nó lại ngược lại các
bạn sẽ thích vào bên trái này các bạn
nhé chuột phải và chọn format axit lại
các bạn sẽ năng xuống dưới này các bạn
sẽ tích vào cái masteri in reverse này
đã xem bấm Ok vậy thì như vậy là diện
cái Doanh thu cao nhất là nó đã được lên
trên rồi bây giờ cái số này Ví dụ mình
muốn cho nó xuống dưới nhé Cả thích là
cái số này gọi nhá được phải là pho mát
các bạn thân lăn xuống này mình sẽ chọn
cái này bổ đây để trong cái phần level
post từng contac đây mình sẽ chọn là
diện họ sẽ tinh và hai đấy thì mình sẽ
chuyển cái giá trị nó xuống dưới nhé lại
như vậy Mình có doanh thu + tích vào đây
mình trước đổi tên là diện top 3 sản
phẩm đúng không top 3 sản phẩm sẽ giải
thích ở đây chọn phân tích và cái dấu
cộng này nha các bạn sẽ chọn gì ạ
xe bồn ở đây này Đấy và đoạn tích và cái
hình tam giác ở đây mình chọn vị trí này
đây mình sẽ chọn sypay lại bây giờ cảm
xúc xích mà cái giá trị nhé là người sẽ
đổi ví dụ mình cho là màu trắng đi sự
động này các bạn nhớ phải là pho mát để
ta lây bù các bạn ăn xuống dưới nhé các
bạn vào cái phần 5 bờ đây này Đây cái
pho mát cốt thì mình sẽ diện Thăng này
phẩy tăng không đấy cậu sân bóng ép để
như vậy mình chuyển nó về cái kiểu phân
biệt hàng nghìn rồi nhìn rất là đẹp đúng
không Đây như vậy Mình có top 3 sản phẩm
rồi đúng không Để bạn gì Các bạn nháy
chuột phải vào cái cô Ba sản phẩm này
các bạn chọn ngu có Coffee creative góp
ý để mình sẽ chọn cái ship mình sẽ ship
một này bạn Ok ở đây là gì Anh không
phải là sản phẩm tốt 3 nữa mà sản phẩm
diện bác Cường bạn là họ sẽ thích vào
đây Bạn sẽ chọn là vali filter còn chẳng
top 10 này lại Bây giờ mình sẽ
ở đó mà mình sẽ chọn diệt Bác đây lại
còn sẽ bấm ok thì như vậy bác đường là
rồi đúng là con sẽ nhấp phải vào đây
mình sẽ chọn diện format Asus bạn kéo
xuống dưới mình sẽ bỏ cái này đi Đấy nó
sẽ nhiệt từ thấp chúng ta luôn Bây giờ
mình sẽ chuyển cái giá trị này xuống
dưới nhé bạn nháy cho phải lại các chọn
format axit đấy Gọi đang xuống đây mình
sẽ vào đây Cái này thì mình lại là lâu
đấy ok Cái này không phải là top 3 sản
phẩm nhưng mà có thể ghi dword tức là ba
cái sản phẩm tổ nhất bạn có thể gõ tiếng
Việt nhé Bây giờ mình sẽ lìa còn có thể
bây giờ cậu nhớ được phải là mình sẽ
copy cái top và các bạn vào desktop này
để cậu có thể can trên V ở đây lại lên
cái này mình có thể con nhỏ để lại để
mình theo dõi là cái sản phẩm là tồi sản
phẩm là tốt đúng không ạ Mình có thể con
nhỏ để lại thôi các bạn vào top này à
anh nghe được phải copy mình sẽ passport
các bạn khác trên về đi Đấy đấy thì như
vậy các bạn sẽ ko chỉnh Tùy các bạn nha
Cái diện tích mà các bạn muốn thể hiện ở
Việt Nam Sport này Bây giờ mình muốn
phân bổ theo cái hiện cái cái cái khu
vực 2 nhà phân phối đúng không Mình muốn
biết là cái phần trăm vậy bây giờ mình
sẽ tạo một cái phần trăm các bạn có thể
tích vào đây mình sẽ gì cả các bạn nháy
chuột phải tiếp các bạn tận dụng cái này
mua Coffee lại christy to copy bạn xem
bấm ok để bây giờ mình sẽ thích nước vào
đây mình sửa là gì cũng có thể ghi là gì
mình phân bổ theo các khu vực nhá khu
vực phần trăm đi gái gọi enter có diện
tích và đây là các bạn có thể nhớ được
phải mình chọn ở trên chai thả Ví dụ
mình cho cái đồ
ở đảo Super Mochi Đây là cái đồ thị cũng
sẽ thích ở đây mình sẽ ghi là gì Đây là
phần trăm theo khu vực đúng không thì
các bạn Các bạn muốn tiêu đề là gì thì
tùy các bạn đã có thể tích vào cái đồ
thị Hải khoảng kéo rộng đây này Đấy cái
đồ thị này nó đại thì về các bạn các bạn
sẽ kéo làm sao để cho nó vừa đẹp theo ý
của các bạn nhé Bây giờ bạn sẽ tiếp vào
đây mình đang làm theo top 3 sản phẩm
của các bạn sẽ kreide các bạn tích vào
đây này mình sẽ có ở xem vào cái thẻ
alarm mình chọn cái Fila đi bây giờ
không phải là sản phẩm nữa người đang
yêu cầu theo khu vực đúng bằng các bạn
sẽ kéo khu vực vào đây này thì nó sẽ là
phân bổ theo khu vực Ok các bạn sẽ thích
là cái giá trị này nhá sau đó
có phải là các bạn xe format datalabels
các loại diện tích và cái castelli lên
đấy thì nó sẽ hiện là diện tên và và cái
giá trị doanh thu của đây lại rất là đẹp
luôn Các bạn nhớ phải này gọi copy người
sẽ bà dsport này con thích vào đoạn
canvê để như vậy Mình vẫn có một cái
dsport về theo khu vực rồi mình sẽ kéo
một cái diện tích hợp lý nhé Đấy Bây giờ
mình sẽ phân bổ tiếp 3 cái đ-sport một
cái đặt theo khu vực 1 cái làm theo gì ạ
Ví dụ mình theo nhà phân phối nữa đi
Mình sẽ làm hai cái nhé Cái khu vực này
có thích một đây các bạn có thể giữ gần
chôn vào tuyệt trái còn kéo ra đây để
mình copy mình sẽ thích ở đây không phải
khu vực nữa mà nhà phân phối nhà phân
phối Gọi sẽ tích vào đây cho mình sẽ vào
cái thẻ alarm có thể chọn là diện còn
chưa chọn cái Philip II
thì mình sẽ bỏ những khu vực ra mình sẽ
kéo nhà phân phối vào đây đấy các bạn
sân bóng này lại các bạn nhớ phải copy
sáng tác bóp sao bạn phết vào đây hai
bạn kéo xuống nhé và cái đồ thị này con
có thể tích là đây toàn thích thì cả kéo
rộng ra thế là nhìn cho nó đẹp các bạn
có thể thêm các cái thành phần nào mà
các bạn mong muốn nhé thì trong cái ví
dụ này mình chỉ là một số két đơn giản
như này cho bạn hiểu thôi ạ Đấy bây giờ
cái việc cuối cùng là riêng mình rất tạo
một cái collections từ các cái slicer
này đến các các and sport này đúng là
con sẽ tích vào cái năm về trước này các
bạn nhớ liệt phải các bạn chọn report
Collection đấy các bạn xem là còn cái
Facebook thấy bộ nào và chưa thích ở đây
mình thích hết rồi đúng không thì ok các
bạn nháy chuột phải và cái tháng này các
bạn chọn report lesson a
sự tích hết rồi nhé nếu như mà cái nào
còn chưa thích thì các bạn hãy thích vào
nhé Tại vì mình đang muốn là diện các
cái slideshare này điều khiển thì nó sẽ
có tác dụng trong toàn bộ các cái biểu
đồ ở đây là khu vực cũng vậy thành tích
hết rồi thì gọi ok lại tại nhà phân phối
cũng vậy nhé để bạn thấy giới tính hết
rồi ví dụ những cái này mà chưa thích
chẳng hạn thế nhá thì có phải tích vào
nhá đấy các bạn muốn Ok thì bây giờ ví
dụ mình theo dõi này có sự tích năm ví
dụ mình muốn kiểm tra năm 2020 đấy nó
chỉ hiện năm 2020 của toàn bộ các cái
biểu đồ này nó sẽ thay đổi theo nếu như
muốn hiện thêm 1 năm nữa nhé thì họ sẽ
tích vào cái Monte này hãy mình có thể
lựa chọn đồng thời nhiều năm lại cảm
thấy ẩm rất là hai ạ thì tương tự cái
tháng nhé bạn có thể theo dõi một cái
thằng bất kỳ nào các bạn mong muốn này
Đấy cảm thấy rất là hai con nếu muốn
hiện nhiều tháng hoặc phân tích và cái
Monte này để đoạn hiện đấy thì các bạn
sẽ thay đổi theo cái
cho các bạn biết được là sản phẩm nào là
tốt nhất tồi nhất và diện cái phần trăm
ở đây là cái ông này sướng bao nhiêu
Nhìn cái biểu đồ này bạn có thể biết
được nhé để tương tự cái nhà phân phối
khu vực các bạn có thể tích và các điều
khiển rất là hay luôn Ok như vậy mình đã
xong cái phần thực hành nhé các bạn thứ
nhất cái câu hỏi của các phần lát bóp
này là diện các bạn sẽ làm lại cho mình
nha các bạn sẽ thực tập nhiều để các bạn
quen đấy Bạn có thể vẽ được cái quay
vuốt và các cái hiển thị hoặc là rẽ các
bạn có thể hiển thị phần trăm ở đây nhá
ngoài cái phần gì ngoài cái thần số đây
là họ sẽ hiển thị cho mình là cái phần
trăm để các bạn có thể làm thêm cái phần
đấy cho mình nhé
Ừ ok những cái sim này có thể ẩn đi nhé
để các thích là cái sim này các bạn giữ
ship và đoạn trích và xếp này Bây giờ
bọn nhớ thật phải lại các bạn sẽ hay đi
tụi mình sẽ ẩn đi đúng không nó chỉ còn
cái les này thôi đấy Ok như vậy là mình
đã kết thúc bài học ngày hôm nay ở đây
cảm ơn các bạn đã theo dõi các bạn nhớ
đăng ký Kênh để cập nhật video mới nhất
của gà cũng như chia sẻ để giúp mọi
người cùng học xem nhé Xin chào và hẹn
gặp lại ở